women don't hey women are like you need
to treat me like a wife before I I like
I behave like a wife put the ring on it
and then I'll be a wife it's like no no
no no no we we expect you to be a
husband before you've even get in our
pants you have to take us out you have
to provide for us you have to take us on
a good time you have to do all this
stuff before we let you have access to
the Ultimate Prize for men so I'm just
trying to show obviously it's extreme
I'm trying to show that we have to women
have to cultivate qualities of surrender
of vulnerability of being able to be led
by a man and to follow him and to serve
him when he needs served yeah now women
don't do that today but that's why if
you flip a coin and toss it your
marriage is going to end and 40 of
first-time marriage is in so what we're
doing is not working and I think 60 of
second marriages and 70 of third
marriages correct um but here and I want
to get the lady's opinion here
um
what you're talking you're saying this
is the corrections are needed across the
board women need to treat a man like a
God and then he'll behave like one he'll
treat you like a queen everyone's like
I'm gonna be treated like a queen but
you act like a little [ __ ] like you're
like you need to do this you need to buy
me this you need to only look at me and
only [ __ ] me women are delusional men
are gonna [ __ ] other women and they need
to get over it straight up straight up
so that's what women need to understand
absolutely
[Music]
women don't like me because I speak the
truth okay so so you put all men in that
category high value remember the higher
the six over six feet make six figures
six pack meaning fit I just like the
sixes six inch over a six eggplant uh
six inch eggplant and then not married
like those are the those are what women
really want maybe some of the stuff's a
little extreme but it's just fun to use
those analogies right but they've done
the pulls on it big strong athletic
money making
correct and we know that 80 of the women
are sleeping with 20 of those men now if
you want a beta male and you want a guy
to make you feel secure and safe and
love you and simpyou somebody you can
have that and he probably will be
loyalty but he'll probably still step
out maybe not as much but here and there
because men just cheat the stats show it
women cheat emotionally so if you want
that type of men tall dark handsome
we're just abbreviating it here you have
to expect that he's going to [ __ ] other
[ __ ] and the more that women can just
get and and understand that okay if you
want that type of man
wow Victoria
I've got to get your because would you
agree that both these ladies are lovely
gorgeous
but you know what I 99 of men cheat like
it's so true like even my hot friend she
got she like the hot wait who just came
out Adam Levine just cheated on a
Victoria's Secret model with like some
dumb Instagram hoes like come on
Menchies like I'm sorry but that doesn't
mean that you ladies are gonna need to
be okay with it no but I don't think
she's saying that we need to be okay
with it well she kind of kind of I can't
I'm saying that you don't have to be
okay with it then go for a lower value
man or a beta or so I'm gonna go for a
beta man and there you go
Mary next time
and that is the Eternal question would
you rather have that Boss Ass Dude right
everything we just talked about the 666
thing is just aptly cool athletic Money
Maker you know gentlemen yeah not
married okay
um but there's a chance that the higher
the value that more he's gonna yeah
there's a chance that he exercises
someone that maybe doesn't have all
those qualities
and he's not you're not that attracted
to him as much money right it doesn't
make as much he's maybe not as good
looking maybe not as in shape what have
you but he's loyal to you and
he'll probably let you lead the
relationship you will lead the
relationship
I I get that these are complete like you
know ends of the spectrum there's always
binary type questions and life doesn't
work that way at least get over six feet
though
so of those three okay hey what would
you pick let's just go let's just
address that life isn't fair so you're
not gonna always get what you want
that's right so my mom always is like
you know date someone who's like 20 less
attractive than you and you'll be happy
and secure because you're gonna be more
into her than she is in to they're gonna
like in our friend group that's what we
say correct yeah but do you even find
those guys who are like no super
attractive attractive okay look I talk
about this on my Tick Tock all the time
even the medium ugly ones have an alpha
male complex so you can't even I mean
I'm having to go like 50. let's try
you're like I'll take so this is
something that women discuss is like oh
yeah so meaning
if you see a guy and he's just like a
super good looking guy or you're like
yeah too much work for me to retain that
guy yeah
yeah he's not gonna simp on you you
like he's just not gonna do it like if I
want to compliment I'll I'll have to ask
and say Hey how do how does this dress
look or I asked him the other day I said
can you tell my butt's been getting
bigger and then he looked and he was
like is it just the pants or and I said
no it's not just the pants but like you
have to if you're with an alpha man
that's getting all that attention from
you're not going to get compliments you
have to ask it you have to be secure and
a lot of women are like oh you're
insecure it's like no I'm not if I I
could land a guy my age in Newport Beach
the land of the MILFs and all the money
and and be taking care of my son and I
taking care for life I I told I told the
cab driver how many offers I got just
this year for that but I would not be
attracted to him not sexually into me
sexual polarity is the most important
thing is what I preach so if you like
that clip click right here to watch
another or if you want to watch the
entire saucecast click right here
[Music]